[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle thomas je suis
sceptique
voilà bah il fallait jeter c'était le
thème c'est sauter le pas alors je vous
l'avons fait ces petits gars des vues
très beau choc septique est un mot qui
vient du grec skeptikos tu veux dire
qu'ils examinent et on doit cette
doctrine qui est assez ancienne
appuieront sadate de 300 avant lorrain
du calendrier actuel et et c'était
plutôt radicale à l'époque c'était une
alliance qui disait alors rien n'est
vrai ni faux ni vrais et faux à la fois
ce qui est déroutant mais qui n'est pas
totalement faux ni totalement vrai et
cette doctrine dont antique
aujourd'hui on a gardé le nom on parle
mais je disais mais c'est un peu
différent aujourd'hui je vous parlais
des édifices modernes s'est nourri des
de l'histoire des idées de la méthode
scientifique mais on va dire deux mots
de la variante antique qui avait deux
objectifs qui étaient les poké donc
c'est la suppression du jugement ne va
pas voir du jugement ne pas avoir des
sentiments et l'ataraxie qui est
l'exemption totale de troubles la paix
de l'âme total donc deux objectifs qui
sont qui restent à l'état de projet pour
un humain normal parce que si tu entends
je monte dans l'absolu on arrive pas on
est toujours en train de lui j'ai vu
qu'on est des humains et l'ataraxie qui
est l'absence totale de troubles par
rapport au monde environnant
je ne sais pas si c'est souhaitable en
fait je suis un peu sceptique du
scepticisme un antique c'est rigolo un
tank version moderne on est plus modeste
que ça on va dire que notre projet c'est
se débarrasser des idées faute d'un
maximum et la stratégie principale c'est
éviter de croire des trucs
or dans le détail on pourrait là je fais
un truc de gros donc voila en gros c'est
ça et c'est pas évident évident mais bon
le sceptique doivent faire ça le
problème c'est que lorsqu'on dit qu'on
est sceptique
le mot est connoté dont vous connaissez
les mots ont un sens c'était le sens ce
que le mou des notes et même sens que
mme o'connor la dénotation dénoter c'est
quoi les mettez ces renvoyée au 13
objectifs habituels est communément
distinctif que le sujet parlant d'un
énoncé quelconque discerne dans un objet
désigné la source et le centre national
des ressources textuelles et lexicales
un bon français c'est le sens propre et
la connotation c'est évoquer en plus
d'un cent stable donc le sens propre une
signification au dépendant du contexte
donc c'est soit aussi dure et on fera
des exemples ça va beaucoup mieux par
exemple le mot rouge renvoie à une
couleur ça dénote une couleur mais sakho
note des émotions fortes une alerte la
colère ou le communisme sans que ça
devient forcément entre soit le mot
cartésien ça renvoie pas certain que
j'ai les cartes mais justin des cartes
monsieur descartes rené descartes mais
aussi à la logique pure analytique aux
mathématiques au rejet des émotions à
tort ou à raison sakho note ça quand on
a le mot cartésien il ya des situations
où on a une personne et on va utiliser
différents mots et donc selon qu'on
utilise le mot mère maman poule marâtre
ou génitrice c'est pas le même message
qui est convoyé et puis ici là sur cette
scène ou de conférences ted nous avons
un beau cercle rouge
il y aura des intervenants y aura des
speakers des conférenciers des tribuns à
des des marques et des prédicateurs où
des militants et selon le mot vous avez
employé
vous n'avez pas vouloir insister sur le
même dimension de la chose ni vouloir
faire voir la même chose à ceux à qui
vous parlez donc les mauvais avec une
connotation c'est un béret faire
autrement et donc j'en reviens au
scepticisme lorsque ça dénote on l'a dit
mais ce que sakho note c'est quoi ces
boutons et négativement être sûr que le
sceptique on a les eurosceptiques combat
très bonne presse
à tort ou à raison on a les climato
sceptiques soient carrément anti science
et pendant tous les gens qui n'aiment
pas trop les versions officielles qui
ont vous dire je préfère et théories
alternatives conspirationnistes il
estime être celtics et le celtic c'est
quelqu'un qui est toujours en train de
critiquer il n'est jamais d'accord avec
vous le c est donc en fait c'est des
gens qui sont un petit peu un petit peu
chiant parce qu'ils sont agaçants c'est
loin très agaçant et parce que ils sont
agaçants on aimerait qu'ils arrêtent et
qu'il se taise
moi si je me tais la conférence est
finie et il est trop tôt donc je vais
continuer si on veut définir le
scepticisme au delà de ce que j'ai dit
au revoir à quoi on peut le
le comparer qu'est-ce qui est la
doctrine opposé au scepticisme assez le
dogmatisme dogmatisme c'est dire nous
ici là on est là et nous on possède un
truc c'est la vérité absolue
on a ses fans partie on a décidé et en
fait il ya plusieurs clips d'artistes
tels que selon là où vous êtes vous
aurez toujours souvent des gens pour
vous dire je sais ce soit dans la
religion évidemment mais dans la
politique dans les arts dans les valeurs
tout ce que vous voulez il y aura
toujours des gens qui vont vous dire là
on détient la vérité définitive et c'est
fini donc en face il faut plutôt avoir
des scepticisme au pluriel parce que
c'est très compliqué et à mon sens
encore jamais vue d'avoir un être humain
qui soit totalement sceptiques
d'absolument tout manière homogène
on a tous des trucs moins d'entrain et
sceptiques qu'on veut tenir pour vrai
qu'on veut tenir pour faux puis on veut
pas en discuter parce qu'un pas que ça à
faire et ça c'est pas être un faux
sceptiques et déjà qu'il va être un
petit peu un peu extremis et qui vont
vous dire moi je veux du t12 absolument
et moi je serai un vrai sceptique mais
celui qui vous dirait moi je suis un
vrai sceptiques
il a une certitude au moins en trop un
vrai sceptiques du coup c'est un peu
compliqué mais il vaut mieux être plus
humble que ça et en gros il faut doser
pour tout est dans le dosage noé quoi 12
et le doute parce que le celtix c'est
quelqu'un qui doute d'abord et dont je
viens produit un autre mot quel mot
zététique qu'on doit henry broc qui
l'appelle comme ça l'art du doute
donc arrête entendu comme artisanat
savoir-faire en synthétique on essaye
d'appliquer un doute utile pas jusque là
pour embêter tout le monde vous savez
sans doute que rien n'est poison tout
est poison c'est la dose qui fait le
poison un principe qu'on prête à à
paracelse en tout cas il n'a pas rendu
est donc le doute c'est pareil tu
accueilles si vous voulez appliquer
absolue les conséquences c'est quoi
c'est que si on dit d'absolument tout à
l'heure on ne sait rien alors on décide
de rien alors on fait rien on s'emmerde
un peu donc si on veut faire des choses
il faut douter mais de manière un peu
raisonnable et donc les sceptiques
moderne considère que le doute n'est pas
une chambre soit on ne doute pas pour
douter m'en doute pour savoir ça a l'air
bizarre en fait on doute pour évaluer
les théories les unes par rapport aux
autres donc on se débarrasse des moins
bonnes pour évaluer les faits
pour voir si on a de bonnes raisons de
croire et si on n'en a pas on les retire
et donc on arrive à des conclusions
provisoires mais qui sont solides parce
qu on a douté avant et donc les édifices
modernes a pour objectif a pour
programme d'avoir un doute raisonnable
donc modérée est d'abord une suspension
du jugement dont j'ai déjà parlé
les poké mais relative bien qu'on peut
pas suspendre totalement son jugement
c'est inhumain
le celtic n'est pas celui qui suspend
absolument sans jugement est celui qui
suspend son instrument dans l'absolu la
source
c'est là que maintenant vous y êtes en
direct avec la source pavot et donc le
sceptique j'ai dit que c'était un coming
out parce que pas parce que c'est une
parodie que vous avez un faire part pour
me moquer des gens qui sont dans une
situation au coming out était un passage
obligé mais parce qu'être sceptique
lorsqu on le dit et quand et convaincant
l'appliquent c'est coûteux en fait
socialement c'est pas toujours facile et
des gens selon leur environnement qui le
paye cher d pourquoi parce que les êtres
humains normaux ont un cerveau qui
marche très très bien mais qui pense
plus vite que que plus vite qu'on ne
peut s'en rendre compte on produit des
inférences et des conclusions basées sur
des intuitions des émotions des
impressions des sentiments des
catégories qui peuvent être vraies ou
fausses
mais ce qu'elles peuvent pas être
justifiées c'est très dur de justifier
une intuition
on le sent que c'est comme ça on sent
que c'est pensant que c'est faux mais le
jugement il est produit en coulisses et
on ça va quand même et parce que c'est
justement son produit extrêmement vite
la personne qui va en douter elle va
juste des désagréables les humains
produisent des catégories alors on a ici
on a un lapin qui est différent d'un
canard que plus de sauvabelin perruches
l'ensemble est différent des poissons
mais l'ensemble c'est les animaux
d'après on les trucs là bas c'est des
plantes à prendre les deux corps un peu
bizarre mais c'est du vivant et autour
on a les objets naturels mais exempt pas
vivant on leur connaît très très bien
et à côté on avait des objets qu'ils
sont mais les factures et les ingénieurs
savent pas très bien et puis on les
catégories particulières qui sont les
autres êtres humains en gros
intuitivement on a tous ce schéma dans
la tête plus ou moins et le schéma
humain de temps il ya plein de petites
cases pour ranger les gens on adore
ranger les gens c'est très mal vu en
fait tout le temps
parce que c'est utile de ranger les
jambes pour savoir comment se comporter
par rapport à eux est la principale le
principal test qu'on fait au départ avec
les gens c est ce qu ils sont comme moi
ou pas comme moi est ce que cette
personne parle comme moi est ce qu'elle
me ressemble
est-ce que s'habille comme moi est ce qu
elles mêmes repères sociaux culturels
est-ce que je peux me notifier est ce
qu'elle est comme moi et quand on répond
oui alors tout va bien on attend d'en
savoir plus tôt plus confiance plus
d'empathie et on cherche plus de contact
c'est pas automatique
la manière d'aller au delà de ça mais
spontanément on a tous câble est un peu
comme ça on fait plus confiance aux gens
qu'on trouve similaire à nous et le
problème c'est que bah du coup moi je
suis sceptique et le sceptique c'est
quelqu'un qui doute des catégories donc
la seppic il
il vous embête parce que du coup il vous
dit que les outils avec lesquels vous
analysez le monde et marche pas très
bien ça produit un inconfort voir une
vraie une vraie souffrance
les gens vous en veulent parce que leur
inconfort il est dû à quelqu'un c'est la
faute à qui aux sceptiques et donc comme
c'est là qu'est le kéké quel drame c'est
que le de quoi est ce qu'on nous d'abord
de choix est-ce qu'on loupe d'abord des
idées que nous rencontrons ou des idées
que nous ne rencontrons pas vous avez
peut-être oui on veut davantage de celle
là parce que les autres on ne connaît
pas donc on doute de celle là donc on va
douter d'abord des choses que disent les
gens autour de nous donc on va ajouter
des dogmatismes des gens qu'on fréquente
donc c'est gratis cela qu'on va combat
questionner on va les questionner dans
l'environnement social qui est le nôtre
donc on va embêter les gens qui sont
proches de nous conséquence quand les
gens vont devoir décider le sceptique
est ce qu'on en fait et ben en fait il
est pas comme moi parce que dès que je
dis un truc qui n'est pas d'accord il
est toujours en train de payer à cause
de ça on a moins d'empathie moins de
confiance et maintenant avec les 70 donc
un vrai sigma 2 social en fait être
sceptique dans une famille très
catholique
outre est musulmane ou ce que vous
voulez outre m
impliqué dans des choses fortes ça fait
qu'on ait rejeté assez fascinant dont
claude ameisen celtic est un acte et
coûteux mais il faut le faire quand même
parce que c'est un acte qui est
libérateur au moins vous vous mettez en
remettez vos actes avec ce que vous
pensez et puis comme on est en 2021 et
que quand même tout va pas si mal que ça
il ya des des des réseaux sociaux
il ya d'autres sceptiques qui existent
et qui peuvent voir un ventre et donc ya
des gens qui vous aideront dans la case
comme moi parce qu'ils s'impliquent
aussi et ce qui est encore mieux c'est
que eux mêmes pourront vous dira t on là
toi tu as tu un dogmatisme laqué qui
reste et c'est rigolo et il vous rend
service en fait parce que les sceptiques
sont vos amis
il faut les aimer rossi et les
sceptiques en fait pour peu que leur
scepticisme niveau de la mène de manière
bienveillante un peu sympa et 21 il faut
les écouter lorsqu'il met en question
vos certitudes alors vous aidera de
douter puisque je vous dis
mais même ça c'est déjà un bon début
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]